if you want to support this channel and
get cool anime merch at the same time
like the dragon sin of Wrath meliodas
feel the wrath of my dragon and the lion
sin of pride esken or praise the Sun
check out our online store link in the
description what is up everybody its
Anna Mak here for anime uproar and in
this video we will be talking about
maybe the single most enigmatic
character in the entire series the goat
sin of lust goal thir recent chapters in
the manga have had some incredible
twists and turns and they also through
go thir into the spotlight as a key
player in a secret plot that has been
over three thousand years in the making
the purpose of this video is to bring
together all of the important
information we have about gol thir and
his plans and to explain why go there
lied to and betrayed some of the people
closest to him finally I will tell you
my theory about what Golder is really up
to and what is going to happen next if
you enjoy the seven deadly sins content
on this channel you want to see more you
can let me know by leaving a like if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
valve and we recently had a poll on
Twitter where I asked you guys what type
of seven deadly sins video you want to
see next the winner was a video on the
friendship between Melly Otis and bonds
so I will be working on that next if you
want to take part in future polls and
help us decide what videos to make next
feel free to follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime abroad because this
video will deal with the very latest
chapters of the manga manga spoilers are
going to follow there is just no way of
avoiding it so this is your warning as
we know go thir is actually a doll who
was artificially created by the demon
Golder an incredibly powerful wizard the
original goal there was the one who
taught magic to merlin thousands of
years ago and we know that merlin is the
current greatest mage in all of
Britannia not only that but the original
Gotha was able to end the entire holy
war by manipulating the memories of the
Archangel mile and everyone who knew him
even the demon king himself and as for
the doll Golder he was created by the
original goal
her to service his proxy to the outside
world while the original growth er was
being held prisoner by the demon king
because he had refused to fight during
the holy war eventually the original
goal thir sacrificed his life in order
to enact the spell that would ultimately
end the holy war and he also used the
dog oh there's power to help him make
this happen but before he died he
bestowed the dalgo thir with the ability
to go off on his own and fulfill his
dream in the present time Merlin states
that Golders magic is so absurdly
powerful that even she as the greatest
mage can only return him to his original
doll form
temporarily because he is a doll go
Thurs body is highly resistant to
physical attacks and he can take the
type of damage that would kill a normal
person and still survive for example
even if his head is lopped off his body
he can simply reattach it and he can
theoretically keep on living forever so
in that sense he is immortal
Gotha has the incredible special ability
known as invasion which enables him to
manipulate the mind and spirit of his
opponents he has various abilities
including reading the minds of others
trapping them inside their own traumatic
memories erasing and rewriting memories
and immobilizing people or even outright
controlling them like a puppeteer the
name of his sacred treasure is Herod and
it allows him to summon two bows made of
purple light or energy that he can fire
at opponents when used together with his
ability invasion the bows allow gold her
to rewrite the memories of a large
number of people at long range and now
that I think about it this should have
been our first clue that gold there and
of course has created the original goal
there could have the ability to
manipulate the memories of a large
number of people at the same time and at
long range three thousand years ago the
doll Golder had tricked molasse culet to
create an entrance to the demon world
prison in order to freed the original
goal her at a critical time during the
holy war the original goal there had
been trapped in the demon world prison
for 500 years and when he escaped he
used the forbidden spell to alter the
memories of Miele and everyone who knew
including incredibly powerful beings
like the demon king himself
the original goal thir knew that his
actions would not only cost him his own
life but also bring suffering to the
people whose lives will be affected by
the spell however he still decided to do
it and he asked the doll goal third to
bear this sin together with him the
question is why did the original goal
third decide to do this why did he
betray the demon clan even though he was
supposedly a demon himself and why did
he sacrifice his own life just to end
the holy war I say supposedly a demon
because we are assuming that the
original goal there is a demon because
he has stated to be a member of the
demon clan and one of the ten
commandments and because he has a demon
mark on his face however at this point I
think that we have to take all of this
with a grain of salt don't forget that
other members of the ten commandments
such as droll and gloxinia were not
originally demons and of course we now
have the example of esta rosa esta rosa
had demon marks and was believed to be
the demon King's own son until we
realized that he was actually the
Archangel mile I think that it is
definitely possible that the original
goal there was not originally a demon at
all but rather a member of a different
race who was forced by the demon king to
join the demon clan but because he never
fully accepted it go Thur was held as
prisoner perhaps Golder was originally
part of the same race as Merlin a
distinct race of wizards that is no
longer around because of the destruction
of their capital belli Alwyn but
regardless of what his race was we have
a pretty good idea of why the original
goal Thor decided to sacrifice his life
to end the holy war from the opening
sequences in the seven deadly sins anime
we know that countless holy wars have
been waged between the different races
for millennia and a conflict between the
demons and goddesses especially has been
an ongoing one these constant wars
between the goddess and demon clans
caused a huge amount of suffering and
you can just imagine how the less
powerful races like the humans kept
getting caught in the crossfire as these
far more powerful goddess and demon
clans went to all-out war with each
other Oh
and over again the original goal third
decided that the only way to end this
constant cycle of war and suffering is
to rewrite the memories of mile the
strongest of the four Archangels as we
are currently learning in the manga mile
is far stronger than we even imagined
and there is no saying how strong he
would have been before he lost sunshine
and it somehow passed on to Eskin or so
the original goal turn knew that the
only way to stop the war was to take
mile out of the picture which
drastically changed the position of the
goddess clan to the point that they felt
that the only way to stop the demons was
to seal them inside the coffin of
eternal darkness however in order to do
that members of the goddess clan had to
give up their own physical forms which
led to the end of the war since both the
demon clan and the goddess clan were now
effectively unable to continue fighting
the original goal therse accra faces his
life in order to make this plan come
true and before he dies he grants the
doll goal there's something he did not
have himself since he was imprisoned by
the demon king he grants the doll gothe
her freedom and the ability to choose
his own path in life thousands of years
later go lhermitte's the princess Nadja
king Bartra sister and he develops a
friendship and eventually a romantic
relationship with her at this point in
his life the doll Gotha is finally happy
and free to live life the way he wants
to with someone he truly cares about
unfortunately princess Nadja
is ill and her heart continues to get
weaker with each passing day
Nadja wishes to spend a moment of
passion with Gotha before she dies and
she eventually dies in his arms but with
a smile on her face Goethe er cannot
accept her death and because her own
heart gave out go third tries to take
his artificial heart that his creator
gave him and to implanted into Naja
Golder makes the decision that he
doesn't care what happens to him he
doesn't care if he dies as long as Naja
the person he loves can live this shows
a massive development of Golders
character he goes from being a doll that
doesn't have any concept of human
emotions to deciding to willingly
without anyone telling him to sacrifice
his own life for another person
her goal Thurs artificial heart does not
work on Naja and he fails to save her
the castle guards then walk in and see
him trying to implant the artificial
heart inside Naja and they accuse him of
killing the princess in some sort of
lustful grotesque ritual and that is why
Gotha is known as the sin of lust
Gotha is so profoundly affected by
Nadia's death that he decides to throw
away his artificial heart which had been
given to him by his creator and he
erases his own memories because he just
can't cope with Naja's death throughout
the series growth err keeps trying to
run away from the tragic events in his
past but thanks to the intervention of
his fellow members of the seven deadly
sins he is now finally beginning to come
to terms with everything so even though
early on in the story we see Golder
doing some immoral things like
manipulating the memories of people like
Jia and the N which at first makes us
think that he has no emotions or that he
might even have some sinister intentions
in reality go third does develop very
real emotion so real that he struggles
to deal with them and he wants to forget
them the progression and development of
his character is actually remarkable
when you think about it as he goes from
a suppose of the emotionless and
sinister manipulator to someone who is
even willing to oppose Chandler's
absolute order to protect his friends
despite the fact that this puts his life
in critical danger
so then how is it possible that Goldar
betrayed the trust of his closest
companions the seven deadly sins by
keeping the truth about mile hidden we
can't forget that even meliodas the
captain of the seven deadly sins thought
that esta rosa was his brother why did
Goethe her betray the trust of his
friends the same friends he was willing
to sacrifice his life for what is his
motivation what is his plan I believe
that everything goes back to the
original goal thir and the terrible
nature of the holy war the dog author is
not a traitor but he decided to accept
his creators belief that the only way to
stop the endless cycle of violence and
suffering brought on by the wars between
the demons and the goddesses was to
manipulate the memories of all of the
important players and to keep lying to
them for their own good however now that
Miele has written
gained his memories Gotha is forced to
come clean and tell everyone the
shocking truth but with that said what
happens next will the fact that my el
regained his memories mean that the holy
war is going to keep raging on and on
like he did thousands of years ago with
millions of creatures caught in the
crossfire
I think that both dalgo Thur and the
original goals are in terms of his plan
may play a key role in what happens next
as I mentioned in a previous video about
Merlin we know from the opening sequence
in the anime that the events of the
story are happening a long time ago in
ancient times when the human and
non-human worlds had not yet split this
seems to tell us that at some point
after the events of the story the human
and non-human world separated I wonder
if Golder will play a role in separating
the different realms from each other
which would of course put an end to the
holy wars for good because the different
races could no longer go to war with
each other because they exist in
different realms or will memory
manipulation come into play yet again
and Gotha will play a part in
brainwashing everyone into thinking that
they are all part of the same race that
they are all equal so that no one race
would be able to go to war against the
other this would mean that the obvious
physical differences between the races
would have to be altered as well but in
a world where such powerful magic exists
you never know I am really looking
forward to seeing how Golders character
will continue to develop in the story as
the manga and anime go on and with that
said let me know what you guys think
what do you think of gold there is a
character and do you consider him to be
a traitor or a hero also what role do
you think that Gotha is going to play in
the future let me know down in the
comments don't forget to check us out on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar a
big shout out to RIF T beads for making
this awesome remix that I'm using as the
background music link to his channel is
in the description if you enjoy this
type of content and you want to see more
be sure to leave a like to let me know
and if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell seriously guys no
one's getting notified anymore you have
to hit that Bell and then hit it like
more times or something I don't even
know as always thank you all so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
Cowboys
[Music]